hello and welcome to another episode of
game squads weekly Game of Thrones show
eye on Westeros that's probably not the
final title but I do like it a lot
apologies for what you're about to see
it is almost time season six kicks off
this Sunday and if you caught our last
episode you should be well-versed in the
biggest plot point of season five so
what better time to put on our tinfoil
hats and go over some of the biggest fan
theories around to try and make some
predictions for the upcoming season
so theory / prediction number one we're
gonna find out who Jon Snow's mother is
one of the biggest fan theories out
there is that R + L equals J Rhaegar +
Liana equals Jon which means that Jon
Snow isn't Ned Stark's bastard at all
but he is still a stark it's not really
made clear but Liana either runs off
with or gets kidnapped by Rhaegar
Targaryen Rhaegar you'll know as being
the son of the Mad King Aerys and older
brother to Daenerys and Viserys this
causes a bunch of problems not only
because Rhaegar is already married but
because Liana is actually betrothed to
Robert Baratheon this is kind of like
the big event that sparks off Robert's
rebellion you know when all the north
bangs together to take on the south it
all sparked off by Liana and Rhaegar
Rhaegar ends up getting killed by Robert
in the Battle of the Trident and the Mad
King Aerys ends up getting stabbed in
the back by the old Kingslayer Jaime
Lannister King's Landing is completely
sacked by the north and just completely
ruined basically and after all that's
happened next dog takes a few of his
friends try and find Liana and they
track her down to this weird place
called the Tower of joy which is this
like weird lonely tower that Rhaegar
built for her by the time they get there
and Ned finds her she's lying in a pool
of her own blood and she ends up dying
we don't know what she died of but it
was probably childbirth
because if you think about it when Ned
Stark returns to Winterfell he's got a
baby in tow so it's not his it's
actually his sister's illegitimate child
who now kind of hazard claim to the
throne so that's where our plus l equals
j comes from Ned Stark's been popping up
in some of the promo material for season
six like we've seen him in the Hall of
faces but also in the full-length
trailer we see what looks like Ned Stark
and a bunch of his friends go to an area
that kind of looks like where the Tower
of joy could be so this could be it this
could be R plus L equals J confirmed we
know that the Wright is a game of
Thrones know who Jon Snow's mother is
george RR martin posed this questions
then way before filming and writing the
series ever started so they know they're
just not been telling us until now
maybe if you're a book reader you just
been waiting for the return of Lady
Stoneheart and I think this is going to
be the season where she finally makes an
appearance so we know that Catelyn Stark
met her demise during the red wedding
and to the phrase but she's resurrected
and brought back by beric Dondarrion
beric Dondarrion is the leader of this
kind of outlaw group called the
Brotherhood without banners and he
himself has been killed and resurrected
by a red priest a follower of the Lord
of Light Thoros of Maya so we know that
it's possible and in the book it
actually happens berrak gives up his
life to bring back Catelyn but the
resurrection like it isn't a hundred
percent foolproof she kind of changes
during the process when she's brought
back her wounds haven't healed so her
cut throat means that she can't talk and
the process has changed her in a way
that she's completely just filled with
anger and has an unstoppable need for
revenge and she's corrupted by rage and
basically she's a complete badass and
she tastes control of the Brotherhood
without banners
I honestly think season six is gonna be
the season that she makes her return it
seems like this series is all about
resurrection not only just like in the
Hall of faces promos and stuff so it
could be that this season is Lady
Stoneheart season and I really hope it
is because she is a badass next up is my
favorite fan theory cleganebowl I just
really hope this happens and if it's
gonna be in any season then we'll have
to be
this one soca game ball is another
famous fan theory that states that the
plugin Brothers of Sandor and Gregor the
mountain in the Hound are going to end
up fighting each other in this epic
showdown to decide the fate of Cersei
Lannister Gregor the mountain is just a
sadist and he's a rapist and a murderer
and when when they're little kids he
shoves his brothers face into a fire
that's why the Hound is all burnt and
he's just had this lifelong hatred of
his brother so how is cleganebowl gonna
happen because both of the brothers seem
to be kind of dead well the last we saw
the hand he was gravely wounded and he
dies off-screen so you know he's
probably still alive but in the book
there's a theory called the gravedigger
theory it says that he's actually been
seen and he's alive and well while
Brienne of Tarth is wandering around
Westeros
she finds this place called the quiet
Isle that's basically a monastery when
she's there she meets this reputable
healer called the elder brother when
she's talking to him she finds out that
the elder brother found the Hound you
know like really badly wounded and
popped him but the elder brother also
says that the Hound is at rest but
Brienne finds the hounds horse who's
actually really famous for being
untamable and no one can ride him apart
from the Hound
and she also sees this really big guy
he's digging a grave and his face is all
covered and he seems to have the same
kind of wound as the Hound had so what
speculated is that when the Hound gets
found by the elder brother and he saves
his life he gives up this persona of the
Hound like all the anger and hatred
inside him so the Hound is put to rest
but Sandor Clegane the man is alive and
well and now deeply religious and the
last time we saw Gregor was the I thing
when he was fighting against over in
motel he won that fight but also he got
pronged
by a poisoned spear so he was gonna die
but then Circe's weird maester Qyburn
said oh I can save him but the process
might change him a bit so it's a really
deadly poison that he got stuck with so
it's highly likely that he died but I
been manage to keep him alive do some
weird dark arts so we've seen him like
live under a sheet and at the end of
season 5 when Circe's walked through
King's Landing a big hulking member of
the Kingsguard just picks her up and so
that you know that's probably the
mountain so when Cersei got arrested
she chose a trial by combat and now she
has the reanimated body of the mountain
to fight for her the faith has the newly
pious pound to fight for them basically
for gain Bowl the next theory then Jon
Snow is alive this is probably
completely obvious but this is how I
think Jon Snow is going to be alive
everyone thinks that he's gonna walk out
I mean it's well known that the stark
children can walk we've seen Arya do it
with Nymeria Brown obviously is a famous
example he walks into summer all the
time and he can even walk into Hodor as
a brand probably like the strongest warg
but Jon Snow can do it too so this is me
this is a much bigger deal I think in
the book he has dreams where he wargs
into ghosts and he does it when they are
scouting north of the war when they're
looking for wildlings and things so to
me it's a big deal so he can do it
but the thing is I don't think that'll
happen if he decides to walk out into
ghosts at the last minute before he dies
then like the actor of Kit Harington
I'll be gone and if he has a claim to
the throne that'll you know just be lost
on a on a dog so I don't think that's
gonna happen although that dog will
probably become like the highest-paid
dog in television history but no I think
this other option is more likely and
that is Melisandre bringing Jon back
from the dead so Melisandre basically
clung on to Stannis Baratheon because
she believed that he was this legendary
warrior of light Azure a high reborn as
Orihime managed to like take on all the
others like the White Walkers like the
last time they tried to come down into
Westeros you know as a prophecy there's
good that he's going to be reborn and
Melisandre thought that was going to be
Stannis and it's kind of obvious that
not Stannis like nothing went right for
that poor guy so the other option could
be that it's Jon Snow
she's a priestess of the Lord of Light
and we know that in their religion like
that magic exists like they can bring
people back from the dead like Thoris of
Maya brought back beric Dondarrion Lady
Stoneheart like we know it can happen
sothe highly likely the Melisandre and
Davos Seaworth are going to work
together to get Jon Snow's body and
bring him back from the dead
there's a line from a dance of dragons
that a lot of people have read a lot
into I pray for a glimpse of Azure hi
what role are only shows me Snow Jon
Snow or the white stuff you decide but I
think it's Worf floppy-haired Jon
alright next is that Jamie is going to
kill Cersei if you cast your mind back
to the start of season 5 you remember a
flashback scene where a young Cersei and
her friend go and visit Maggy the Frog
who is a fortune teller in the books
it's made really clear by maester Qyburn
of all people that Maggy the Frog is
actually Maggie the Magi who uses this
dark blood magic in order to tell
Circe's fortune actually it starts like
the 14 starts are really good it says
that Cersei will marry the king and
become queen and they shall have three
beautiful children which happens but
then the fortune kind of sours it says
that a younger more beautiful woman will
come and cast down everything that
Cersei holds dear that could be one of
an any number of people that could be
Sansa that could be Margaery that could
be Daenerys but when talking about
Circe's children the fortune says it
will be their crowns
God shrouds meaning that all three of
them will die and we're well on the way
to that right now
and then it gets even worse for Cersei
and when your tears have drowned you the
valonqar shall wrap his hands around
your pale white throat and choke the
life from you
bankai is high Valyrian for little
brother
which is why says he spend all of her
life being completely horrid to Tyrion
not only did he kill their mother during
childbirth but he's their little brother
that could ruin everything for her
but as her gaze is so fixed upon Tyrion
she's completely overlooking another
little brother of hers her brother
part-time lover and father of her
children
Jaime Jaime's kind of gone through this
arc of redemption as the story's gone on
where Cersei is just remain is like this
baseline horrid human being so this
theory is kind of far-fetched it's kind
of out there but I still love it okay
the last one possibly the most
far-reaching and Stroke watching of them
all dragon has three heads so this
theory means that you've already bought
into the theory that Rhaegar Targaryen
is Jon Snow's father and that Jon Snow
is actually a Targaryen this theory also
states that another one of our favorite
characters is also secretly a Targaryen
Tyrion Lannister
hear me out so Tywin Lannister Tyrians
father was hand of King to the Mad King
Aerys and Aerys basically made no secret
that he had a massive thing for Tywin's
wife Joanna Lannister like he was really
super creepy about it like on their
wedding day he tried to like touch her
up and stuff and it caused a big rift
between him and Tywin so while they were
at King's Landing it could be that Aerys
sort of just exerted a power play over
her or seduced her but either way it's
theorized that Tyrion is actually king
heiresses son what's interesting to note
is that Tyrion not only was he born a
dwarf but he was also born with a tail
and I've been reports in the Targaryen
bloodline of babies being born malformed
and crucially one of them was born with
a tail so that's where a lot of people
are getting this evidence from so if Jon
and Tyrion are also Targaryen
then you have to think about the other
one Daenerys so remember when she was in
house of the undying she has this weird
vision it's a man who could be Rhaegar
and it's a woman who could be Liana and
now holding a baby and they basically
say you know this baby should be called
a gun and that he's the prince that was
promised which is another name for as or
high and that his is the Song of Ice and
Fire
and then the man who could be Rhaegar
looks at Daenerys in the eye and says
there must be one more the dragon has
three heads so if you think about it
Daenerys has three dragons and each of
those require a rider so you've got two
Narus you've got Jon Snow and now you've
got Tyrion Lannister so that's why when
Tyrion and Daenerys met that's a big
deal
so if Jon Snow gets resurrected by
Melisandre and comes back and he meets
the other two that's the dragon has
three heads and that's that's a great
theory and I love it I don't think
things will tie up that neatly but if
they did that would be quite cool
because those seeds have been sown like
throughout all the books so that would
be great
so what do you reckon do you think any
of them hold water personally I'm
holding out for a game bowl I know it
could be far fetched but I really really
hope it happens let me know in the
comments or come find me on Twitter I'm
at Lucy James games of course we don't
have long to wait season six kicks off
this Sunday so for detailed breakdown
slash spoiler cast make sure you come
back to games for calm on Monday for all
the Game of Thrones gossip